I have to think hard about what stage
fright is because I I suppose I don't
really allow myself to go there
I came to acting by accident I I went to
art school and I went to a college where
I was training to teach art and you had
to do a subsidiary course and I was told
the easiest cause to do that required
the least amount of work was the drama
course so um I signed up and that that
proved to be trove and but it meant I
had to start performing and start acting
and I think that was the first time I
experienced stage fright or nerves and
feeling very faint and dizzy my hands
was that tingling and I find it very
difficult to learn lines but I was
fortunate in that people when they saw
me they weren't aware of what was going
on inside and they were saying it's good
what you're doing is good I began to
just get confidence from people there's
the support of people saying that what
they saw externally whether I was dying
inside or not was was something positive
I get more nervous when I'm me when I'm
a character in a play I can I'm fearless
I don't it doesn't worry me and I enjoy
it and I enjoy going onstage every night
there are times when I appear as me and
I have to talk about something and then
the nerves start to come back but I
think it's the cruel answer is that
those nerves are to do with self regard
and that you are thinking that you are
the important thing in this the
presentation and of course you should be
thinking about who you're talking to
they
that's that is that what you need that's
what you need to focus on it's less to
do itself and more to do with you what
you can be communicating to be to the
audience or the other person you're
talking to with the other person at an
interview
so yeah the I think the cruel way to
tell somebody is it try being less
selfish let's think less about yourself
and more about the person you're talking
to and and then it you'll work it out
that way I was lucky in the in that the
early work I did when I was still quite
nervous and apprehensive about it or it
was company work and I was a member of a
company and the focus wasn't on me I
wasn't a star performer I would yeah I
was playing good roles and leading roles
and sometimes small roles in plays but
that were it were I always knew I had
the support of every actor around me and
we needed each other that's what I love
about theater is that interdependency we
have and I just think that when you've
got that and when you you know inwardly
you could think yes it's it's some
displays about me this this scene is
about me but I think outwardly you're
sharing it and you're sharing you're
sharing the responsibility and I think
that's what what's important is to is to
listen to your other actors I mean that
it's it's part of my rehearsal process
is very much to listen to what other
actors are saying about my character
what they say to me and that I learn
about my character from the way they
react to me and that makes for a
experience I need that other actor they
need me at its best it's a it's it's a
it's a wonderful wonderful experience
you